[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à 7,8 et tout
d'abord bonne saint valentin à toutes et
à tous merci nous avoir rejoints pour
cette nouvelle émission dans quelques
instants avec notre invité elisabeth de
feydeau nous parlerons de parfums nous
parlerons de gourmandises à l'occasion
de la saint valentin et puis dans 30
minutes comme tous les jeudis ce sera la
page économique avec voeckler bonsoir on
va parler saint valentin
pas tout à fait pas plutôt abordé la
semaine de l'emploi exactement bonsoir à
tous demain que commence la semaine de
l'emploi tous les jours de nouveaux
événements ateliers jeux forum de
l'emploi pour nous en parler ne
recevront christine villain vice
présidente de la communauté
d'agglomération ainsi que le président
le directeur pardon de la maison deux
reprises j'ai les mandats de président
alors on profite de rajustement de la
présence de jean luc romero le directeur
pour parler du concours de la jeune
entreprise merci car on vous retrouve
dans une demi heure mais tout d'abord
comme d'habitude les titres les sujets
qui seront développés au cours de la
prochaine heure carlos ghosn le patron
de renault est venu au technocentre de
guyancourt présenté des chiffres de son
groupe ils sont bons et bénéfice net de
1,7 milliard d'euros en 2012 et malgré
tout le pdg de renault estime
indispensable de maintenir un plan de
compétitivité les salariés ne
l'entendent pas ainsi
les 45 ans et les plus de 45 ans à
l'honneur à la cité des métiers de
trappes poursuivre une ateliers un
atelier de rédaction de cv après plus de
vingt ans de vie professionnelle il est
parfois difficile de bien savoir
promouvoir son expérience et dans les
yvelines les seniors représentent
toutefois 20 % des demandeurs d'emploi
la saint valentin on va en parler dans
quelques instants à la maison de la
poésie un local à lui en cours c'est
l'occasion de déclarer sa flamme
laurence earl prépare un spectacle pour
samedi soir nous avons suivi les
dernières répétitions et puis une
exposition à la maison félix nous
envoyer les images à montigny le
bretonneux elle est signée un muriel
choir ce une autodidacte qui a choisi
l'aquarelle sous forme d'expression mais
tout d'abord donc comme je vous en
parlais dans les titres cette
mobilisation au technocentre renault de
guyancourt
carlos ghosn en personne est venu
rencontrer lé salariés une visite privée
à laquelle n'ont pas été convié les
journalistes ils sont donc restés devant
l'entreprise accueilli par les
syndicalistes anthony rech johan abou
baker et patrick jacques de dixmude
étaient sur place en ce début d'après
midi
carlos ghosn veut gelé 30 % de sa
rémunération
renault n'échappe pas à la crise en 2012
le bénéfice net de la firme a baissé de
plus de 15% mais avec une plus value de
924 millions d'euros le pdg de la marque
au losange s'est donc présenté au
technocentre de guyancourt face à des
salariés excédés c'est une provocation
pour les salariés de cette entreprise 30
% de salaire en moins et un parent pas
en moins c'est une partie de son salaire
qui est j'allais sur les quatre ans qui
viennent
si on tirait 30% aux salariés même du
technocentre des usines on ne pourrait
plus vivre
selon le quotidien les échos cette somme
avoisinerait les 430 mille euros mais
carlos ghosn resterait assuré de
percevoir plus de 2 millions d'euros
pour 2012 le versement n'interviendra
qu'en 2016 la condition que l'accord de
compétitivité soit validé par les
syndicats est appliqué à la lettre c'est
un chantage même pas de pression c'est
un chantage si vous signez pas d'accord
je ferme des usines
c'est carrément du chantage pour les
organisations syndicales donc la cgt
elle refuse ce chantage elle dit on peut
faire de la compétitivité mais autrement
pas avec un accord comme ça environ 300
salariés dont des ouvriers sonia de
lardy étaient réunis devant
l'amphithéâtre où se tenait la réunion
avec carlos ghosn
suite à l'annoncé de carlos ghosn les
syndicats ne comptent pas en rester là
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des représentants
cgt de la marque doit se réunir demain à
paris vendredi 15 février pour envisager
d'éventuelles manifestations la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
nous allons parler bien sûr pendant une
large partie de l'émission de la
saint-valentin puisque vous le savez
c'est la fête du 14 février
alors évidemment la 14 février c'est une
affaire de coeur et j'ai envie de dire
de tous les coeurs car c'est aussi la
journée de sensibilisation aux
cardiopathies congénitales
alors en france tous les ans il naît
entre 6500 et 8000 enfants cardiaques et
cela représente un tiers des anomalies
constatées à la naissance dans 85% des
cas l'origine de la malformation est
inconnue ces chiffres font des
cardiopathies congénitales les
malformations les plus fréquente est la
première cause de mortalité infantile
nous avons rencontré ce jeudi annie
bordeaux les tiny monteyne c'est la
vice-présidente de l'association
nationale des cardiaques congénitaux
elle préside le comité ile de france
l'association qui fête d'ailleurs cette
année ses 50 ans elle a répondu aux
questions de huit frères et chiffons
l'écoutent alors le 14 février pourquoi
parce que sept
date a été dix ans à l'initiative d'une
maman vivant aux états unis en 1999 qui
a eu un enfant atteint d'une
cardiopathie congénitale et qui a pensé
que cette date du 14 février qui reflète
bien le coeur dans tous et dans tous ses
états les amoureux etc et tous nos
enfants ayant le coeur mal formés ou le
coeur malade il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de progrès qui ont été faits
grâce disons aux amis aux synthèses qui
sont pratiqués maintenant sur le sur le
foetus
les progrès qui sont faits disons que
les enfants sont opérable pratiquement
dans les premiers jours de vie et les
opérations ne sont que palliatifs comme
elle pouvait être il ya disons 20 ou 30
ans maintenant en général le mieux à ses
envies en général pas ce qui est bon
chaque petit coeur est un peu différent
mais les opérations sont pratiquement
fait est définitive il ya des enfants
qui ne sont pas opérables tout de suite
et qui disons grandissent disons
normalement avec un suivi régulier
grasset toute l'action des cardio
pédiatre qui est vraiment sensationnel
on les rend les remercie du fond du
coeur nous sommes très très fiers de
fêter nos 50 ans la date pour l'instant
n'est pas arrêtée malheureusement nous
n'avons pas encore trouvé un endroit un
peu grandiose pour fêter dignement cet
événement le bilan qu'on peut faire
d'abord on peut remercier les fondateurs
de l'association monsieur alain porcher
qui étaient tous deux atteints d'une
cardiopathie congénitale donc il ya
cinquante ans c'était osé de de
travailler sur une association cette
association continue de vivre comme tout
asos on ne sommes que des bénévoles nous
essayons de faire le maximum
auprès des délégués dans tout dans toute
la france qui est quand même assez
remarquable c'est que nous nos cardiaque
10 alors que ce n'était pas du tout le
cas il ya encore une vingtaine d'années
nous arrivons à voir des cardiaques qui
ont 50 60 ans il y a quelques années
malheureusement ce n'était pas le cas
donc c'est quelque chose de très
important
si vous voulez des informations
complémentaires vous pouvez contacter le
site de l'association nationale des
cardiaques congénitaux qui s'affiche ci
dessous à l'est le 14 février vous le
savez forcément vous le savez c'est la
saint valentin est justement que faites
vous ce soir le soir de la
saint-valentin et bien les
saint-quentinois ont répondu aux micros
de matic de blain et aux oceane simon
qui sont allés recueillir leurs
témoignages
bon j'ai prévu un gâteau et puis il
rouse j'ai pas de moyens énormes donc
voilà ça reste symbolique enfin un petit
repas spécial ce soir ah ben moi
j'attends ce qui va m'arriver je prévois
rien vous l'avez devant vous voilà c'est
un petit bouquet chocolat 40 ans de
mariage ça se fait enfin plus de 40 ans
maintenant que moi je sais rien parce
que à mon âge vont chercher pour les
jeunes la saint valentin je donne les
fleurs à madame eva parce que c'est le
jeu la fête c'est la démarche avec la
famille âgée au restaurant avec mon mari
oui donc on va
dust est à nouveau resto ce qu'on aime
bien tester voilà